you have to kind of explore the
environment around you by splattering
the place with your I don't know if it's
long or short all I know that it is a
you look sick maybe I'll be or forehead
with a widow she's rubbing on my it's a
new mobile game where myself
PewDiePie cinnamon toast can Kouta and
Hoover hacks anova will all be to see
you can level the most in one week's
time okay I can't wait to fight over and
over again for you guys oh what's your
favorite thing about marklar everything
yeah it's fine his boys
baktun voice if you're trapped on an
island with your whole family who would
you first when I first I had people
which is my mom my sister my sister you
encountered the I'm gonna this it's
gonna be fun time why can I not probably
gonna invade that guy through his big
gaping oh you don't like a little tongue
thing do you also he your uncle no yeah
you may remember Tyler he was just in LA
me with Wade we had a ton of fun which
oddly enough I Tyler for way longer than
a lot of my friends what was a fourth
grade fifth grade I really went by
second grade I've got three new scars on
my might much literally looks like the
Big Dipper right now if you know what I
mean and we're gonna take it down a
little bit with a little tug big burrito
makes you larger larger lighter and
slider this doesn't sound like what I
want from my I best hurry
sharks are bad but me put okay dick
together does your character have a long
yes can your character I highly doubt it
what a beautiful compliment will it be
hey whoa hey we're moving a bit fast
here
hi are you trying to sleep I'm so sorry
about that I have you